i would like to multiply 9 times 10 to
the ninth power
times negative 2
times 10 to the negative third power
and so i encourage you pause the video
see if you can work through this
all right so the first thing i would
want to do is let's just change the
order of multiplication let's multiply
the 9 and the negative 2 first and then
we can multiply the 10 to the ninth and
10 to the negative third power so if i
were to change the order we could write
this as 9 times
nine times
nine times negative two
times ten to the ninth power
times ten let me do that
this color
times 10 to the ninth power times
10 to the negative third power
times
now what's 9 times negative 2
well 9 times 2 is 18 time times negative
2 is going to be negative 18. so that's
negative 18.
and what is 10 to the ninth times 10 to
the negative 3. well if i have a number
raised to some exponent times that same
number i have 10 i have the same base
for both of these times that same number
raised to another exponent this is going
to be the same thing as that number as
that base raised to the sum of these
exponents this comes straight out of our
exponent properties so this is going to
be 10 to the
10 to the
plus negative 3 power 9 plus actually
let me use those colors so you see where
that 9 and the negative 3 came from
plus
negative 3 power
9 plus
this color i'm having trouble changing
colors 9 plus
negative 3 power now what's this going
to be well this is going to be equal to
negative 18
times
times 10 to the 9 plus negative 3 same
thing as 9 minus 3 which is 6.
negative 18 times 10 to the sixth power
and if you wanted to think about what
number is this 10 to the sixth that's
one with six zeros this is a million
negative 18 times a million it's going
to be negative 18 million or we could
say negative or we could say negative 18
times 10 to the 6 either way but this is
another way we could have written this
we could have written this as negative
negative 18
let me write the zeros with the green
just for fun negative 18
negative 18
million either way is a legitimate way
to represent this number